AND I'M THANKFUL WE LIVE IN A
FREE COUNTRY.
WHERE YOU ARE FREE TO SAY STUFF.
MAN WE HAVE HEARD A LOT OF THAT
HERE.
>> THE PRESIDENT WHO IS NOT FIT
TO LEAD WAS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING CRAZY IN FIVE MINUTES,
ONE HOUR TONIGHT OR TOMORROW.
WHAT MORE DO YOU NEED TO HEAR
FROM HIM TO START THINKING
25th AMENDMENT OR SOMETHING
ELSE?
GREG: I WISH SHE WOULD SLEEP AT
NIGHT.
ANYWAY THEN THERE IS THIS.
>> THAT THE PRESIDENT IS A
FOREIGN AGENT.
GREG: IT COULD BE A ROBOT TOO.
WHO COULD FORGET THIS?
THIS PRESIDENT HAS RADICALIZED
SO MANY MORE PEOPLE THAN ISIS
EVER DID.
GREG: THAT DESERVES AWARD.
JUST ONE MORE.
>> HE DOES LOSE WHICH WILL BE A
HAPPY EVENT IT WOULD BE STUNNING
I'M NOT LEAVING, CALL THE
MILITARY.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER IF THIS MAN
REALLY WOULD DO THAT.
GREG: WHAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT
IS THIS.
>> AMERICA NOW HAS THE HOTTEST
ECONOMY ON EARTH.
WE HAVE TAKEN ACTION TO BRING
BACK AMERICAN JOBS.
WE WILL MAKE AMERICA WEALTHY
AGAIN.
WE WILL MAKE AMERICA STRONG
WE WILL MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: ALL RIGHT, LOOK I THINK
THEY ARE CLAPPING FOR ME BUT
IT'S OKAY.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN TRUMP
AND THE MEDIA MAY NEVER CHANGE
BUT WHEN TALKING HEADS ARE
SAYING OUTRAGEOUS THINGS DOES
NOT MEAN MAYBE THE COUNTRY IS
RELATIVELY OKAY MAYBE THINGS ARE
RUNNING SMOOTHLY SO THERE IS NO
RECEPTION TO TALK ABOUT OR AN
INTERNATIONAL CRISIS KNOCK ON
HAYWOOD AND CHICK-FIL-A DELIVERS
TO YOUR HOUSE NOW.
SO THINGS ARE PRETTY GOOD UNLESS
YOU ARE A CHICKEN.
SO YEAH YOU WILL HEAR A LOT OF
BAD STUFF FROM THE TALKING HEADS
AND THE PRESIDENT LOOKED HER
RIGHT BACK OUT THEM.
THE ACTORS ARE ALL OVER THE TOP,
THE DIALOGUE IS CHEESY AND THE
STORYLINES ARE RIDICULOUS.
HE WON'T LEAVE IF HE IS NOT
REELECTED.
COME ON YOU.
START A COUP?
SHUT UP YOU FESTERING GASBAG.
[APPLAUSE]
BUT WITH ANY GOOD SOAP WE THE
VIEWERS JUST SIT THERE AND THINK
, OH MY GOD I CAN'T STOP
WATCHING THIS AND IT IS BUT
THAT'S OKAY.
YOU DON'T TAKE IT SO SERIOUSLY.
AS FOR THE TALKING HEADS WILL
THEY BE THANKFUL FOR TRUMP?
IS IT GOOD FOR THEIR BUSINESS TO
MAINLY BECAUSE WITHOUT HIM THEY
WOULD BE EXTREMELY BORING.
THERE IS NOTHING WORSE THAN
THAT.
WELL, MAYBE THERE IS.
>> IT'S FUN TO GET TOGETHER WITH
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
GREG: ALL RIGHT LET'S WELCOME
TONIGHT'S GUEST A PRESCRIPTION
FILLER AND MY FAVORITE
PAINKILLER.
THE HOST OF THE RADIO SHOW
DR. DREW LIVE DR. DREW PINSKY.
[APPLAUSE]
LOOK AT HIM.
HE IS FUNNY AND HIGHLY STRUNG
LIKE A TENNIS RACKET MADE FROM
CLOUD DUST.
COMEDIAN JOE.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG: YOU KNOW FOR THANKSGIVING
SHE AND HER CAT SHARED A
SWANSON'S TURKEY DINNER.
NASA REVIEW REPORTER ANDY LIVES
IN TWO-TIME ZONES BUT HE DOESN'T
EVEN PLAY.
FORMER WWE SUPERSTAR AND TYRUS.
ALL RIGHT DR. DREW COULD YOU
IMAGINE IF WE HAD INSTEAD OF
TRUMP WE HAD HILLARY.
WOULD WE BE ENJOYING THIS KIND
OF I DON'T KNOW BONANZA?
>> YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER NEWS IS
A COMMERCIAL ENTERPRISE AND THEY
ARE ADDICTED TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE CONTROLS THE NEWS CYCLE AND
THEY ARE ADDICTED TO HIM.
THEY GET RATINGS BUT HAD HE NOT
BEEN ELECTED PRESIDENT THERE
WOULD HAVE BEEN SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PEOPLE THAT PUT THEM IN THE
PRESIDENCY WE WOULD BE HEARING
FROM IN THE WORST WAY.
GREG: THAT IS TRUE.
HOW AM I DOING?
>> YOU ARE DOING GREAT.
SOME OF THE NEWS OUTLETS ARE
ADDICTIVE.
GREG: I WAS REFERRING TO THE
WINDOW CLEANER.
I'M NO LONGER DOING THAT.
>> YOU DON'T YIELD THE PAIN ANY
MORE?
GREG: JOE LOVES THE JACKET.
MEMBERS-ONLY IS BACK IN STYLE.
COUNTRY IS DOING OKAY SO WOULD
THE WORD ABOUT?
>> I AM WORRIED THAT CRAZY IS
BECOMING A RELATIVE TERM NOW.
A POLITICIAN LIKE TRUMP WHO SAYS
WHAT HE THINKS AND DOESN'T TRY
TO HIDE IT MIGHT SEEM NUTS TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
GREG: HE IS SAYING BASICALLY
EVERYTHING THAT IS ON HIS MIND
AND MOST OF THOSE COMMENTS WHAT
WE THINK I GUESS.
>> I THINK THE CRAZY ONES SEEM
LIKE THE PUNDITS.
THEY SAY CALL THE MILITARY.
THERE'S NO SUCH PERSON AS THE
MILITARY.
YOU CAN'T CALL UP AND SAY HELLO
IS THIS THE MILITARY?
[LAUGHTER]
GREG: THAT'S SUCH ROUX.
CAT, WHAT IS YOUR TAKE IS HERE
ON HOW IT'S GOING AS WE ARE
GETTING TOWARDS 2019?
>> I HAVE SOME ISSUES BUT NONE
OF THEM HAVE TO DO WITH TRUMP.
GREG: WOULD YOU CARE TO SHARE
THEM?
>> MY DAD TOLD ME NOT TO DO THAT
ANYMORE.
I JUST TALKED TO DR. DREW NOW.
I THINK THEY DON'T REALIZE THAT
THEY LOVE IT.
IF TRUMP DIDN'T SAY SOMETIMES
OUT THERE THINGS THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO TALK ABOUT.
THEY JUST LOOK AT TWITTER AND HE
SAYS HE'S TWEETING IT 3:00 IN
THE MORNING AGAIN.
I CAN WRITE ABOUT HOW HIS
UNHINGED ARE CRAZY AND EVERYONE
IS GOING TO LOVE IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO ACTUALLY DO
ANY RESEARCH ANYMORE.
GREG: IT'S SO EASY.
MEB IN SAYING IT FOR MYSELF.
THIS HAS BEEN FUN AND EASY BUT
BEING A KID AND BEING ABLE TO
HAVE ICE CREAM FOR BREAKFAST,
LUNCH AND DINNER THAT'S WHAT
IT'S LIKE IN THE MEDIA FOR TRUMP
YOU JUST FEEL SICK ALL THE TIME.
YOU HAVE EATEN SO MUCH ICE CREAM
TYRUS.
>> YOU ARE IN A FAST-TRACK TO
DIABETES TOO.
FORGIVE ME FOR TALKING SLOW.
LOOK EVEN WHEN HE DOESN'T SAY
ANYTHING THEY WILL JUST MAKE
SOMETHING UP.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE MANY GOOD
QUOTES AFTER THE MIDTERMS SO HE
IS MAD.
THE WHITE HOUSE START.
THE LIGHTS ARE PROBABLY OFF.
THEY HAVE TO.
THERE'S PROBABLY A RULE LIKE IN
MY FOOTBALL LOCKER WERE USED TO.
>> THE SIGN BEFORE WE GOT THEM
PLAY.
LITERALLY WHEN THEY COME OUT OF
THE LOCKER ROOMS, LET'S JUST SAY
THEY DO THEY WILL COME OUT AND
SAY TRUMP RALLY 16 TIMES PER
SEGMENT.
EVERY TIME YOU MENTION HIS NAME
YOU DON'T HAVE A STORY, MAKE
SOMETHING UP.
GREG: HE PROVIDES THREE THINGS
FOR A GREAT STORY.
HE CAN BE THE HERO, THE VILLAIN
AND HE PROVIDES THE FOCUS WHICH
WAS THE OPPOSITE OF PRESIDENT
OBAMA THE MEDIA SCRUTINIZING HIM
BECAUSE HE COULD GET IN TROUBLE.
YOU CAN GET TRUMP CASSEROLE,
TRUMP EGGS, IT TRUMP'S SAUSAGE,
TRUMP POTATOES.
I'M MAKING YOU HUNGRY.
THE OTHER THING TO I THINK THE
MEDIA IS UPSET THAT IT'S BECOME
A BIFURCATED IDEA.
THEY LONG FOR THE DAYS WHEN I
WAS A MONOLITH WHEN EVERYBODY
WAS BEHIND ONE VISION AND IT WAS
THE MYTHICAL WALTER CRONKITE.
NOW IT IS CHANGE IN THE TALK
ABOUT DIVISIVENESS BUT IT'S
BECAUSE THERE'S ANOTHER
ALTERNATIVE.
>> THEY CONFUSE NEWS WITH
OPINION AND TALK SHOWS WITH
NEWS.
GREG: I'M NOT SURE.